هذا وقد اعلنت كتائب القسام ان عناصرها
اغاروا من احد الانفاق على قوه صهيونيه
راجله وقاموا بالاجهاد على خمسه جنود شرق
خان يونس وقالت كتائب القسام تمكنا من
تفجير عبوه مضاده للافراد في قوه صهيونيه
راجله تقدمت صوب فتحه نفق شرق خان
يونس عن سير العمليات من حيث التحليل
العسكري معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العميد الياس
لنبدا معك بعمليه سحب هذه الفرقه ال 36
كيف وجدت هذه
الخطوه عبد القادري لا يجب ان يؤتمن لعدو
فكيف مع العدو الاسرائيلي اليوم لا تزال
ثلاثه فرق تقاتل 126 في الشمال 98 في
الوسط ت 99 في الجنوب وهي التي صحب منها
قوه الدف دفان او ما يسمى يعتبرونها على
انها زبده الزبده يعني
هي يعني الفرقه المهمه سحبت الى الضفه
الغربيه وهي في الضفه الغربيه من العام 86
على ما اعتقد هي متخصصه وهي تعمل ويقال
على سبيل المثال للحصر انها هي من
يعني
قتلت شيرين بعقله يقال حسب البحث يعني
فاذا انت في مرحله جديده هذه الحرب وصلت
الى نقطه الزروه في
الشمال القتال
الكثيف الشديد هو في الوسط وفي خانيونس
ولا اعتقد ان هذه الفرقه صحب الفرقه 36 هي
تحول اساسي هي امر طبيعي بالعمليات
العسكريه حتى انه عبد القادر عندما تقاتل
فرق
هناك ما يسمى بالتاك فورس يعني لكل حاله
من الحالات معينه تستلزم قوى معينه على
سبيل المثال بمهمه معينه قد يستلزم مدرعات
قد يستلزم مظليين هندسه الى اخره قد يؤتى
وتشكل قوه من عده فرق لهذه المهمه عندما
تنتهي هذه المهمه يتم فرض عقد ما يسمى
بالتاسار وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه نقلا عن
عسكريين ايضا يحذرون من ان سحب هذه القوات
من الشمال ربما قد يؤدي الى عوده المسلحين
كما تقول وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه الى
هذه الاماكن من جديد هل نحن امام عدم وضوح
رؤيه حتى داخل المعسكر الاسرائيلي ام انت
ايضا ما زلت في اطار التحذير من هذه
الخطوه الواقع الميداني ومن يخطط ومن
يقاتل على الارض هو غير من موجود في غرفه
العمليات او حتى في الصحافه اليوم في
الشمال تم تسريح بنهايه ديسمبر باخر
ديسمبر تم تسريح خمسه الويه من الاحتياط
لاعاده ضخها في الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي اثنين
انسحبت القوات الاسرائيليه لتثبيت
والانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه والانتقال
الى عمليات معينه يستعمل فيها وسائل جديده
من هنا كثره القصف البعيد
من البحر من المسيرات ومن المدفعيه وذلك
بناء على معلومات معينه تقول ان هناك قوه
معينه لوحدات المقاومه موجوده في مكان ما
يطلب العمل المدفعي او الدعم الناري
لتنفيذ عمليه معينه وهذا امر يختلف عن
الوسط والجنوب في الوسط مثلا عبد القادر
المهم اليوم هو تقطيع الوسط خاصه فصل
المخيمات من هنا منطقه زوايده التركيز
عليها لماذا لانها نقطه وسطيه تسيطر
على صلاح الدين طريق صلاح الدين وهي يمكن
ان تصل الى عده مخيمات في نفس الوقت مره
اخرى لواء الياس اعادت القاده العسكريون
في اسرائيل الى التحذير بان عدم تقديم
رؤيه للمرحله القادمه في هذه الحرب قد
يؤدي الى تراجع في الانجازات كما قال رئيس
الاركان حيث حذر الحكومه من تراجع انجازات
الجيش كما جاء ونقلته القناه الث عش
الاسرائيليه في حال عدم تحديد المرحله
القادمه من هذه الحرب كيف نفهم هذا الربط
بين تحديد المرحله القادمه وتاكيد ما يصفه
الجيش بانجازات في قطاع
غزه ايضا عبد القادر الحرب تخاض لاهداف
سياسيه دائما البعد السياسي هو الذي يضع
الاهداف السياسيه تترجم عسكريا على ارض
الواقع ولكن الترجمه العمليه على ارض
الواقع اذا اصطدمت بصعوبات يجب ان ترتفع
مجددا وتعود الى البعد السياسي لاعاده
ترسيم الهدف السياسي هذا الامر كما يقال
مصدوم لا تزال القياده السياسيه تقول ضرب
حماس مرحله ما بعد حماس تحرير راهم بالقوه
ولكن الواقع الميداني يعكس مختلف وهذا
الامر خلق
معضلات مهمه لاسرائيل معضله جيو سياسيه في
المنطقه معضله سياسيه في الداخل ومعضل
عمليه تكتيكيه غير متناسبه مع بعضها البعض
من هنا هذا
التخبط شكرا لك من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي